[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 16 mars bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale voici les titres
sitôt débuté qu'elle doit déjà se
résoudre à se mettre en pause la
campagne de vaccination en pharmacie est
interrompue conséquence directe de la
suspension temporaire du vaccin
astrazeneca en france comme dans
plusieurs pays européens
un reportage dans une officine de
montigny le bretonneux
une épidémie de rhinopneumonie touche
actuellement le monde équin des cas ont
été enregistrés en ile de france sous sa
forme respiratoire la maladie et
ressemble à une grippe est très
contagieuse elle est compétition est
annulé les centres équestres sont sous
vigilance invités de cette édition
vincent klein président du comité
départemental d'équitation des yvelines
et puis bientôt deux nouveaux courts de
tennis à elancourt l'actuel complexe
sera détruit et des ménages est toujours
au sein du parc des sports guy boniface
les travaux devraient durer dix mois un
mode de transport est également à suivre
dans ce journal avec l'inquiétude du
département des yvelines face au tracé
francilien de la ligne nouvelle
paris-normandie
[Musique]
mais le taux d'incidence est le nombre
de nouveaux contaminée pour 100000
habitants dépasse désormais les 400 en
ile-de-france l'hypothèse d'un
reconfirme en plein donc sur la région
car c'était le seuil fixé dernièrement
par jean castex le premier ministre a
évoqué d'ailleurs pour la première fois
aujourd'hui qu'une forme de troisième
vague débuté en france et l'île de
france
elle est en sursis les mots choisis par
valérie pécresse
dans une interview à france 2 la
présidente de la région a affirmé ne pas
s'opposer à l'idée d'un nouveau
confinement si les mesures sont je cite
justifiée et proportionnée et mesurée
est des premiers patients ont été
transportés dans les hôpitaux de
province pour désengorger les services
de réanimation franciliens et j'ajoute
qu'un conseil de défense sanitaire doit
se tenir demain mercredi
la vaccination devait a démarré lundi
dans les pharmacies elle est déjà
interrompu avec la suspension temporaire
du vaccin astrazeneca en france décrétée
par emmanuel macron quelles conséquences
pour les officines éléments de réponse
avec eléonore sinoquet et robin bronze
elle devait démarrer sa campagne de
vaccination ce mardi 16 mars
mais les annonces du président de la
république emmanuel macron hier sur la
suspension du vaccin contre le coc vite
astrazeneca a reporté le démarrage pour
la pharmacie de l'espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux la suspension de
l'utilisation du vaccin de 24 heures
donc si retard doit être doit être pris
ce sera un retard de 24 heures donc en
soi on n'est plus à ça près ça fait un
an qu'on est dans cette situation donc
c'est pas 24 heures qui vont changer
grand chose
le problème c'est la perte de confiance
que l'on va avoir vis-à-vis de ce vaccin
qui n'a pas déjà pas bonne presse
cette suspension fait suite à un certain
nombre de cas de caillots sanguins chez
des personnes ayant reçu le vaccin en
europe l'elysée attend l'avis de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments pour
remettre l'astra seneca sur le marché
mais pour romain souk et le problème
c'est aussi l'approvisionnement
on avait jusqu'à hier une centaine de
demandes par jour
deux personnes dans la cible vaccinale
pour se faire vacciner en pharmacie avec
un flacons de dix doses on va pas très
loin donc ça ne cause plus de problèmes
qu'autre chose
l'officine est aussi confronté à un
autre problème logistique la commande de
vaccins pour les médecins généralistes
en tant que pharmacie référente elle
doit alimenter une vingtaine de
praticiens pour attribuer les flacons on
doit se connecter sur un portail dédié
du lundi au mercredi
recommandée pour chaque médecin le
vaccin pour la semaine d'après avertir
les médecins comme a reçu c'est ces
fameux vaccin ça nous demande du temps
d'organisation du temps qu'on n'a pas
forcément pour le moment ces problèmes
tout comme la campagne de vaccination
sont suspendus la décision de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments est attendu
pour ce jeudi
en attendant la reprise des injections
dans les pharmacies 13 centres publics
de vaccination sont effectives dans les
yvelines
ce sont les mairies ou les communautés
d'agglomération qui s'occupent de leur
gestion parfois difficile le reportage
de célia gars de son go cela fait deux
mois maintenant que dix premiers centres
de vaccination ont vu le jour dans les
yvelines sur décision du préfet du
département
toute l'organisation logistique
matérielle et humaine repose sur les
communes et les collectivités
territoriales
même si l'état prend en charge la
logistique des dos ce ne sont plus les
préfectures qui gère l'organisation des
centres de vaccination sur les
territoires comme cela a pu être le cas
au moment de la crise h1n1
il ya ensuite le fait qu'il ya une telle
centralisation et donc c'est aussi à
nous en nos responsabilités et d'être là
pour organiser le fait d'avoir davantage
sur repoussés vers ceux qui ont lu les
ressources matérielles et les belles une
organisation importante pour les mairies
qui doivent gérer les listes d'attentes
en fonction des doses disponibles
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
compte 270 habitants mille personnes
sont sur liste d'attenté pour la seule
ville de versailles
je vous avouerai que c'est ça un peu
complexifier les choses mais il parce
qu'il ya deux entrées possibles donc par
l'application groupon le site autolib
et puis par des listes d'attentes qui
sont constituées dans les mêmes
autre difficulté pour les communes
trouver du personnel soignant
disponibles qui sont déjà eux mêmes
submergé par les différentes vagues
pandémie donc c'est à nous de réaliser
cet encadrement sanitaire un encadrement
administratif avec nos personnels de la
lille et puis on n'y a rejoint également
du bénévolat et c'est grâce à toutes ces
forces volontaire que les mairies
peuvent réagir rapidement
comme lors du week-end du 6 et 7 mars ou
cinq mille doses supplémentaires ont été
distribués dans les différents centres
ça voulait dire quand quelques heures et
je dis bien en quelques heures il
fallait prendre la décision d'ouvrir le
vélodrome durant le week end ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
mais c'est pas tout de l'ouvrir ça veut
dire qu'il faut des médecins il faut des
infirmières et infirmiers quatre
nouveaux centres ont ouvert il ya deux
semaines dans les yvelines à
saint-cyr-l'ecole sartrouville crêpière
et les mines une économie avec le bilan
des investissements directs étrangers en
2020 présentée ce mardi l'an passé les
investissements internationaux ont été à
l'origine de la création de près de onze
mille emplois en ile-de-france dont 40%
rien que pour les départements de la
grande couronne
un record pour le territoire et ce dans
une année marquée par la crise sanitaire
à la majorité des emplois étaient
générés par les centres de décision les
services aux entreprises et la recherche
et développement
en revanche les secteurs très dépendants
des échanges internationaux étaient
fortement impacté l'hôtellerie tourisme
a perdu par exemple 70 % d'emplois en
2020 les états unis en tête suivie de
l'allemagne et du royaume uni sont parmi
les premiers investisseurs en ile de
france
mais depuis la fin janvier le monde
équestre et touché par une épidémie de
rhinopneumonie une maladie qui peut être
mortelle pour les chevaux et les
compétitions sont actuellement à l'arrêt
les centres équestres sont sûres sont
sous surveillance quelques cas ont été
détectés dans la région aux yeux qu aux
écuries de plaisir en revanche les
équidés se porte bien mais la vigilance
reste tout de même de mise
mélanie poker et bixente mayence insisté
ban être aux petits soins comme chaque
jour à plaisir l'épidémie de
rhinopneumonie n'est pas d'actualité
les cavaliers n'ont pas connu de
concours juste avant l'épidémie
mais le personnel et les cavaliers sont
attentifs déjà qu'on avait des mesures
sanitaires mises en place ceux liés aux
coville donc de déplacement de port de
masques et puis avec le couvre-feu on a
déjà un flux de personnes limitées au
club il faut rester vigilant de toute
manière on n'est à l'abri de rien mais
voilà on reste prudent dans le sens où -
ma fenêtre elle est vaccinée non je suis
inquiète pas trop après c'est plus pour
c'est possible qu'ils aient certains
chevaux de propriétaires qui sont pas
vaccinés et l'anti ferait les écuries de
plaisir accueille plus de 80 chevaux des
montures pour le sport et le loisir 30
propriétaires leur font confiance et le
manque de compétition depuis quasiment
un nom qui se fait sentir
la dèche ou ce qu'on appelle -
valorisation donc on doit céder
propriétaire qui me confient des shows
pour les valoriser sa serions évidemment
ça se fait en compétition et là s'est
arrêtée les shows et valorise pas donc
ils prennent moins de valeur ça n'arrête
pas mais ça même une petite pause dans
le commerce et nous le commerce c'est
une source importante pour pouvoir
survivre
la rhinopneumonie a débuté à la fin du
mois de janvier en espagne 70 chevaux
ont été contaminées une dizaine on est
décédé la fédération française
d'équitation a prolongé le lundi 15 mars
la suspension des compétitions jusqu'au
11 avril
et avec mon plateau vincent klein
bonsoir bonsoir avec le président du
comité départemental d'équitation des
yvelines qui recense un peu plus de
150 clubs est ce que à l'image de ce
reportage la situation actuellement dans
les yvelines est ce que c'est plutôt à
l'inquiétude qu'elle laisse place la
situation n'a vu dans le reportage c'est
plutôt de la vigilance pas forcément
d'inquiétude mais de la vigilance oui
pour l'instant dans les yvelines on n'a
pas vraiment de cas recensés ce sont les
cavaliers qui seront montées du concours
en espagne en ile de france je crois
qu'il ya plusieurs cadres dans le 77 oui
pour l'instant dans les yvelines
on reste très vigilant le rôle du comité
justement dans une telle situation c'est
un rôle d'information est ce que les
clubs justement les structures vous
appelle pour obtenir des informations
ouais beaucoup d'informations relaye les
informations on obtient de la fédération
du comité régional d'équitation d'île de
france
on essaie de communiquer au mieux avec
les clubs justement ces clubs ils sont
nombreux à vous appeler aujourd'hui par
rapport à cette situation
ils sont nombreux à être inquiet bien
sûr il nous appelle pas forcément
directement nous il ya beaucoup de
bouche à oreille qui se fait par rapport
au voisinage
ils sont inquiets et ils restent très
vigilants bien sûr ils vouent leur
conseillez quoi aujourd'hui d'être
vigilant sur la situation peut-être de
confiner parce que il ya des chevaux qui
sont confinés actuellement utilise ce
mot c'est vrai que ça peut faire sourire
avec la crise sanitaire actuelle mais en
tout cas c'est le mot qui a utilisé en
ce moment bien sûr entre nous on appelle
la rhinopneumonie un petit peu le navire
le corps d'un virus voilà c'est un petit
peu le même principe
donc on reste très vigilant la
fédération a recommandé de déplacer le
moins possible les chevaux pas de gros
rassemblements
c'est tout ça qu'on essaye de relier la
vaccination si possible ou pour le
moment pas forcément alors c'est pas un
vaccin obligatoire
du coup à les vétérinaires disque
vacciner aujourd'hui c'est déjà un petit
peu tard puisqu'il faut une primo
vaccination un rappel un mois c'est un
vaccin qui pourrait être relativement
efficace doit être fait tous les six
mois
donc c'est un petit peu trop tard
malheureusement pour un vacciner mais la
rhinopneumonie ressemble à une grippe
dans sa forme respiratoire c'est une
maladie qui est connue des vétérinaires
mais plusieurs clusters on l'a dit sonné
après une compétition en espagne et ça a
été dit dans le reportage la fédération
française d'équitation a acté l'arrêt
des compétitions jusqu'au 11 avril en
france
est-ce que déjà avec la crise sanitaire
dans les yvelines n'est plus forcément
de compétition déjà s'envaser encore le
nombre de compétitions avait beaucoup
diminué seuls les cavaliers
professionnels justifiant d'un statut
professionnel pouvait concourir
donc ça réduit quand même beaucoup la
compétition mais c'est des cavaliers ça
a été dit dans le reportage qui ont
besoin de faire concourir leurs chevaux
pour les valoriser pour les
commercialiser ensuite plus justement
l'un des impacts c'est le fait que les
chevaux ne puisse pas concourir il ya
une perte de valeur ça ça peut être
l'une des conséquences sont vraiment ces
lectures il a qui sont impactés dans les
dents les poneys clubs de la compétition
était déjà à l'arrêt pour les poneys nos
cavaliers de club pour cette population
de cavaliers ça change pas grand chose
dont sont vraiment pour les
professionnels qui vivent ou qui
dépendent de la valorisation et du
commerce de leurs chevaux et c'est une
épidémie j'ai envie de dire dans une
autre avec la crise sanitaire du coc
vide 19 qui on l'imaginé a eu des
conséquences sur le monde équestre déjà
est ce qu'il ya eu un impact
quantifiable est ce que vous avez perdu
des licenciés avec la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus alors nous on a eu beaucoup
de chance et on a eu une belle campagne
menée par la fédération française
d'équitation et par le comité régional
d'équitation
d'île de france et est du coup les poney
club ont plutôt fait une bonne rentrée
au mois de septembre
d'abord on est un sport d'extérieur on a
pu fonctionner ce qui n'était pas le cas
de tous les sports donc on a fait une
plutôt bonne rentrée d'une manière
générale il ya combien de licenciés
environ dans les yvelines dans les
yvelines 21000 21 millions donc on a
compris
pas forcément d'impact justement il ya
une adaptation alors vous le disiez
l'excitation aussi la pratique du poney
était en extérieur donc est la plus elle
a pu continuer pendant cette crise
sanitaire
on imagine que les centres équestres lui
tout de même s'adapter face
il a fallu bien sûr bien sûr s'adapter
ça n'a pas toujours été facile
un maintenant je pense que tout le monde
a bien compris que les chevaux avaient
besoin de sortir besoin de devoir du
monde d'avoir de l'exercice physique
c'est sur cette base là qu'on a réussi à
ouvrir nos centre équestre poney club
voilà en adaptant beaucoup évidemment
faisant très attention
on doit on doit tracer un petit peu là
les allées venues de nos cavaliers les
sorties de nos chevaux et c'est donc pas
mal de paperasse et de papier à faire le
tourisme équestre a pu se poursuivre
d'une quelconque manière on sait qu'ils
allaient qui rendent au qui se déroulait
dans les yvelines
chaque année notamment alors les qui
rende à une lueur en 2019 dans les
yvelines
hélas cette année en 2021 il est prévu
au lion d'angers à côté de saumur
et pour le tourisme équestre et un petit
peu plus compliqué puisque sur la voie
publique
ces six cavaliers maximum enseignants
inclut donc accompagnateur de tourisme
qui est un guide de tourisme et qu'est
ce ça réduit un petit peu la taille des
groupes ce n'est pas facile d'être une
dernière question sort de ces
thématiques avec les yvelines aussi qui
ont été touchés comme d'autres
départements l'année dernière par un
phénomène de mutilation des chevaux ce
qui a suscité pas mal d'inquiétudes et
un protocole vigilant cette idée qui a
été signé avec la préfecture des
yvelines est là et la filière équine
dans le but de renforcer justement la
sécurisation du monde des équidés ce que
de ce point de vue la sérénité est
revenue aujourd'hui sur le territoire
des yvelines oui je crois que c'est
mieux on en entend beaucoup moins parler
je pense que tous les clubs ont été très
vigilant on fait très attention en a
profité d'une aide de la région pour
s'équiper un petit peu de caméras pour
surveiller nos prairies voilà je pense
que pour l'instant c'est un petit peu
retombé en entend moins parler
le couvre-feu est peut-être au moins
pour ce problème la merci d'un sans
craindre d'être passé en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
comité départemental d'équitation des
yvelines transports avec la ligne
nouvelle paris normandie qui fait son
retour dans l'actualité ce projet dax
ferroviaire date de plus de 30 ans est
le département des yvelines a fait part
de son mécontentement concernant le
tracé entre mantes-la-jolie et paris qui
a été validé et retenu pour le moment
par l'état ont fait le point sur le
dossier avec eléonore sinoquet c'est un
vieux serpent de mer dont on parle
depuis les années 90 la ligne nouvelle
paris-normandie le 20 novembre dernier
un nouveau comité de pilotage s'est
réuni avec état sncf et parties
concernées pour lancer la phase 2 du
projet pour rappel la lnpn est un grand
projet ferroviaire qui doit se dérouler
en trois étapes et qui a pour objectif
de rallier plus rapidement la normandie
et paris
la première étape s'est achevée fin 2020
et la deuxième s'est ouverte avec ce
comité de pilotage où est ta région
ile-de-france et régions normandie ont
validé le financement et le lancement
d'une nouvelle phase d'étude et de cons
certes à sion cette deuxième étape doit
aussi définir les tracés entre paris et
mantes en ile-de-france est rond et
barentin en normandie
et c'est le tracé francilien qui a posé
problème au département des yvelines
en effet l'état a retenu le tracé sud
plutôt que deux autres choix cela
impliquerait donc que la lnpn
traverserait en souterrain la forêt de
saint-germain-en-laye de ce côté pas ou
peu de problèmes
en revanche la sortie du tunnel à
hauteur de hors jeu valve pose question
et inquiète les élus yvelinois la lnpn
doit ensuite rejoindre morainvilliers
puis mantes-la-jolie et enfin la
normandie mais sur ce tracé figurent des
champs captant des terres agricoles ou
encore des habitations depuis novembre
dernier c'est donc l'incompréhension qui
règne comme en atteste le vice président
délégué aux mobilités pour le
département des yvelines
ça c'est acceptable ni pour le
département des yvelines est ni pour les
agriculteurs dans l'absolu nous sommes
pas obstiné nous ne sommes pas contre
quelque chose
on demande simplement que ce soit
compatible il faut que cette ligne qui a
son intérêt pour les normands ne soit
pas qu'une addition d'inconvénients pour
un des départements traversés par l'invs
c'est ça la difficulté est chez légitime
l'autre interrogation est donc
inquiétude c'est le financement
le coût global avoisinerait les 6
milliards d'euros la ligne nouvelle
paris normandie est espéré pour 2030
mais le projet date des années 90 alors
rien n'est moins sûr de voir émerger
cette nouvelle ligne ferroviaire d'ici
dix ans ce geste de solidarité pour la
jeunesse patrick magne auteur d'un
recueil de poèmes a décidé de venir en
aide aux étudiants en difficulté
il a reversé les droits d'auteur de son
ouvrage pose aux métamorphoses avoir 20
ans en 2020 au fonds de dotation de
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs installé
à montigny le bretonneux patrick manias
étudié à plus jeune et a souhaité je
cite contribué à son petit niveau comme
l'a t-il confié à nos confrères de 7,8
actu avec la crise sanitaire environ 20%
des étudiants en france vivent désormais
sous le seuil de pauvreté et nous
refermons selon al à elancourt l'actuel
complexe de tennis des ménages les
nouvelles infrastructures resteront au
sein du parc des sports guy boniface
huit nouveaux courts de tennis vont voir
le jour
et le chantier débutera d'ici quelques
semaines patrick jacques de dixmude et
justine brasil quatre courts couverts et
quatre courts extérieurs vont prendre
place à elancourt d'ici la fin de
l'année
objectif renouveler l'offre tennistique
et les infrastructures actuelles devenu
vétuste
ici par exemple nous sommes dans
l'actuelle halles qui a plus de 30 ans
de d'âge et à différentes problématiques
d'étanchéité d'humidité donc qui rend
très difficile la pérennité de la
pratique du tennis
les travaux devraient durer dix mois de
nouvelles infrastructures qui répondront
à des exigences environnementales pour
cela différents choix technique de
matériaux ont été opérées nous sommes
orientés sur une charpente en bois en
lamellé-collé exactement satin mélèzes
qui seront de provenance française
nous nous dirigeons vers une conception
où il n'y aura pas donc de chauffage
dans la halle principale couvertes mais
au contraire une gestion de l'humidité
de la ventilation qui sera pilotée avec
une isolation qui sera tout à fait
importantes y compris jusqu'aux bad et
des fondations
le futur complexe tennistique restera
implanté au parc des sports guy boniface
d'elancourt il prendra place sur un
ancien terrain de football et il nous a
paru important de replacer le complexe
au tennis tic sur cet emplacement lors
qu'ils n'avaient plus vraiment d'utilité
objectif transférer l'activité tennis et
d'ici la fin d'année 2021 pour libérer
les bâtiments actuellement occupé par le
club
ils seront ensuite détruit pour
accueillir le projet de commissariats
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines budget total
du projet 3 8 millions d'euros
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]